it is a welcome and a joy to say hi to
julianne moore
[Applause]
you are so beautiful you look so good
congratulations on your show
i'm so happy for you thank you spoken by
the woman who literally is
my beauty style hair eyes
skin nose face and decorative icon by
the way
we'll get into that but your family like
your love story with your husband is
such relationship goals and i know you
just posted something
about your anniversary and i remember
years ago hearing you two got together
you had made this
film and you fell in love and
yeah i just i your your love story is
such a relationship goal
well i will tell you you know what's
really funny about it is that you see
years ago it was
24 years ago that's what's shocking to
us we're like
we met 24 years ago can i ask you a
weird
personal question like you and your
husband
are so amazing like do you have any tips
for people
on like an awesome like union
marriage like do you have a secret do
you have something to
turn to like i i i think a lot of us
you know would love to know if you have
any tips or insights
i think i mean the only thing that i can
say i think that you both have to really
want to be married
i i do i do feel like i've seen
situations where things aren't working
out for people because
one of the one of the members of the of
the
couple doesn't want to be there so as as
i think if you're both
invested in it working out and that and
uh that's important and then you really
have to have a good time my god you have
to
i think they really have to make you
laugh if they don't make you laugh
it's just deadly um and somebody
asked me that if it felt like a long
time and i was like oddly no
it doesn't i mean i think that's what's
that's what's been nice about it it
doesn't feel like a long time
and but now i mean our kids are our kids
are 18 and 22.
how old are your kids now um they're six
frankie's six
i'm sure seven and olive turns eight
like any second
so oh my goodness i know are they in
school virtually
they must be they went they went back um
so and i had such a struggle with it
because as a parent i wasn't sure
and for the show's sake i was worried
about what they were going to bring back
in but then i thought oh my god what a
hollywood stage nightmare mother i would
be like you can't go to school because
mom can't get sick at her job
guess what we're just rolling the dice
because every time you try to plan
it's so terrifying and everything keeps
having to pivot anyway so i feel
like it's almost rude to wrestle anymore
and just well you know
my daughter um was a camp counselor at
this little camp
you know that she that she went to when
she was a kid she's always a camp
counselor there and she had three and
four-year-old girls
and the counselors all wore masks but
the kids didn't because they were too
little
and everybody was fine they were all
okay and those little kids were all over
her
you know so i do think with testing and
everything like that things can be done
safely but it's hard it's really hard i
know all of a sudden a hug
has so much more than just a hug
you're like will i get sick hugging you
will i make you sick this is a lot going
into a quick hug
wait is your daughter on tick tock
uh yeah have you joined her for some
tick-tock
there might have been a couple but you
know nothing i don't i
oh no um yeah there might have been
something i think there was one where
i was doing the dishes and she went with
some tik tok were you supposed to like
do something with your mom or something
anyway i i participated in that without
my knowledge
so i'm excited that we both have a
love of design yes
yes absolutely it's my big it's my hobby
it's my
uh my big hobby where did it all start
for you the love of design
it was my mother you know i mean i i
don't think i realized
how much i was absorbing from her but
she was the kind of person who really
cared how things
looked and she um you know my parents
were students for a really long time so
i never had any money so she would do
things like
make her own slip covers she's always
sewing things and refinish furniture
herself
and she loved to tour historical homes
and stuff she would bring me along with
her and she
she would do things like organize the
silverware drawer a certain way just
because it looked better
and i realized that i just i just sort
of absorbed it all and i
and stuff that i care about now too but
yes all i want to do is look at
architectural digest that's my favorite
thing
so your mom is like martha stewart and
marie kondo
before they existed she kind of was
i mean she was i think not not at that
same level
but yeah she definitely was interested
in that stuff and
and it just rubbed off i think sometimes
in the world of design
you know things are expensive or they
come from you know another person's
taste
and so your mom with like how she made
things that's like
gifting and design like the best things
are stuff of what you bring to the table
your craft your sense of style
oh my gosh yeah absolutely it's funny
when my kids were little and they but
they would bring home
all of these things you know they bring
home so much artwork um i wouldn't i
didn't keep all of it you know but i
always found something that i would
that i really love that they made and
i'd frame it or or or keep it around
and it's sort of indistinguishable from
the other things that i've collected
because i was even specific about that
but
it has to have some kind of meaning to
you i mean that's what makes
that's what makes a home interesting and
i think even in terms of furniture
designers
i'm i'm always interested in seeing
their their hand you know their craft
that's that's what i i love to live with
it's a representation of
people and what they do